jumping in less than 10 seconds here we
go 64 players one-minute war zone rated
1818 average rating here we go time
handicap adder a outer ring is that
array gonna move look at the time left
there's only 25 minutes gotta shake that
30 minutes this is a 30 minute
tournament I'm gonna get the win I'm
gonna be up on the the leaders I'm gonna
be the leader of the pack
come on that's 15 seconds give me the
points it's been 15 seconds this should
be game over look at ah man they're
gonna make me wait what a start
anybody else somebody else has a win or
a quick resign or something
ah man come on here let's go let's jump
into another game c5 who's playing those
planes playing oh oh no oh no is there a
universal problem about these guys are
they playing yes okay we got action less
than 10 in my game who's winning here
who cares
all right game time give me the points
20 and actually two leaders
okay a few twos and where and where all
right I got him
I gotta get that knight move down a bit
better I'm still still in training a
little bit with this non accelerated
mouse there's the accelerated dragon in
the accelerated Mouse variation that I
was running with for the longest time
all right all right the bishops getting
squashed he's getting squashed no no not
so fast you see you see what would it
just happen right there I would have not
just won a piece
I thought the bit Oh what is going on
oh they resigned okay six you see that I
got some points for that a decent amount
of points no no uh-huh
ah Man Man Man Man okay let's do this
finally okay let's do this well look at
this trickiness on f7 if I ever fall for
that and I am gonna fall for that
hang on I'm gonna try and trap that
Queen how far fetch is that oh it's not
too far
oh man wasn't that funny
it wasn't that funny why you laughing so
hard wasn't that funny it could happen
to the best of us man how far fetched
was that not far fetched at all boom
boom the Queen goes down check tricky
Knights tricky forks forks forks forks
forks killer rook no they resigned back
to tournament 12 twelve seven six all
right I was trying to I was gonna hunt
that Queen down it was gonna take
forever before I had my rook in a spot
to do that but I was I was shooting for
it shoot for the stars shoot for that
Queenie nine points worth kill the Queen
kill that clean setting it up Oh creepy
crawler so streak out is this when you
call it is this the creepy crawler I
even know what that is am I saying that
pawn push I did hear about that but I
don't even know what it is let's get
that night out of there avoid exchanges
I want to trap that night he's running
short on squares he must be scared if
you're sure ten squares you must be
scared
dr. Seuss see for the nights running
back uh-oh incoming the nights gonna
land on d6 and be very excited very
excited captured towards the Sun unless
you have a good reason not to I don't
have a good reason not to post up a
night in the center
push your f-pawn create open files
capture app on here it's got to be good
doesn't it probably give a check on here
on here give a check on here where's the
mate making one and then two unavoidable
no clock tick no it's not back to
tournament 20/20 a couple twelve eleven
ten all right less than twenty five less
than twenty five V Silva V Silva is on
the steam ah they could beat me to it
no he didn't okay they're trying to get
rid of my dark square Bishop weren't
they yes they are
yup earn on push Bishop out I have yet
to commit my center pond so I have a lot
of I don't know what this story is with
that Queen was she was she up to
I have I have flexibility with my pawns
in the center and now I'm committing in
some way so maybe I could get at this
pawn or maybe just even get to this
square it's a sensitive point that's
Bishop not around to watch over that I
get out of there night I cannot deal
with you let's open this up and then my
knight wants to jump right in here he's
gonna love it isn't he and the bishop
coming here could be juicy juicy square
Knight right here what's that even
leading to I'd maybe I should just take
the bishop when it moves no I like my
knight too much I take my rook my knight
wants to be here
so my bishop can see is the knight gonna
play here look for for if I might allow
it
I can do this I don't want the dark
square bishop to come off now my light
square bishop can see I get post up here
I have this covered enough what am i
doing why this isn't even preventing g4
I have this covered enough 18 seconds no
time less than 10 seconds 7 6 5 anything
anything
any move any move any move any move any
move this games not gonna finish back to
chairman 30 30 2019 all right burn the
earth bearing the earth gambit
gambit against burn the earth here we go
okay f7 has a lot of my attention okay
they're gonna grab that let's take this
and then it's a little bit scary but I
want to sneak over to the age file this
is not a good move what I just did I
think 94 would have been great I just
want to take here and get it this square
uh-oh it's not really leading to
anything fantastic though okay let's
back up this Bishop is dead my opponents
did playing without a piece to piece
it's like I have a two piece advantage
right now to be samanage right here is
me if I could get my Queen their queen
here next is actually really good isn't
it
or a rook here with Queen takes right
now just pumped Bishop takes oh I had
that for a while didn't I
I had that move for awhile back to
tournament 42 Oh No is this gonna be a
runaway
42:20 wenneck squatty 'm uhq for short
alright I'll practice my mouse skills
here get that Mouse working get him
working is gonna sniff this out why did
I do that and is that really necessary
Wow my phone's doing it just take that
pond next time would you and take this
one I think maybe tuned that's better do
that
I have checks and stuff over here that
ponds gonna fall isn't it oh yeah yeah
let's do that let's do that that's a
bright one at the Queen Queen was gonna
play to d4 look at the trickiness can
you believe this right here oh man okay
Queen trade I could I could live with
the Queen trade in almost every
situation that was the reason I can deal
with that pins pins pins the Bishop's
pin the bishops still pinned bishops in
trouble trouble for the bishop
rick is dead about the exchange and the
pig is on the second 15 seconds gotta
take the bishop otherwise it's a free
piece get some imbalance no imbalance
now I'm just up a piece now I'm up a
rook full rook tricky rook Pig
one Pig a second Pig problems on F
pac-man pac-man looking for mates where
the mates there it is its main back to
tournament 42:20 no oh there we go 42 41
40 oh all right let's go here let's go
less than 20 know I have 56 556 it
wasn't updating
okay all right all righty
French Bishop b4 win a war we know why
I'll see five was men they missed it are
they gonna do see five now straight dark
scrub bishops oh it's a free bishop
their dark squares are in big trouble
big trouble on the dark squares I want
to hit that upon that's on a dark square
uh should just played here the Knights
gonna play here and then here man I
didn't want to I want to hang out of
this guy it's gonna be taken though dark
squares still dark squares I want to get
here well I should get castle probably
right maybe just take that or something
don't take like this if that happens
okay I'm up a piece here just Castle
complete my development twenty-seven
okay we're having let's go at this
connected Knights twenty two twenty two
tix it's gonna get kicked away I'm gonna
drop that night haha oops oops oops oops
my knight gonna get trapped you might
get trapped that little bugger gave that
piece right back take a pond he's free
he was free wasn't he
hey here guess so
oh that's a wonderful move to make yes
everybody loves doing that to the rook
oh look at these rugs man look at these
rooks they are having a lot of fun
fortunately the clock is my friend he is
my friend
run pond give a check
run back just for fun push here run back
here and then back here and then here
and then here and then here it doesn't
matter time burners it's all I have
I can't like right back wow that was bad
that was very bad again u HQ u HQ I've
played I think like six times already
between this tournament and the one
before didn't I huh
okay this Bishop needs to do something
else next time next time it needs to
definitely do something else
Oh problems down a piece oh the kitchens
I'm getting kitchen sink right now I am
getting kitchen sink kitchen sinks
everywhere kitchen sink kitchen sink man
where is the main I'm getting kitchen
sink kitchen sink there we go back to
tournament Mandy sixty no ninety
somebody is seventy now oh oh oh who's
this
somebody has 47 oh that's that can't be
right
see see whatever see stay see whatever
Oh
the Queen's gonna take for a second I
thought I didn't have enough support on
that okay it's gonna be okay you know
it's coming
Queen trade haha my favorite thing to do
my favorite love Queen trades everybody
should love them shouldn't they let's go
night you know you want to belong right
there on Dean stop that tricky stuff
clamp down on this right here I might
have to babysit stuff you talking about
no babysitting in chess King right here
I got so fast I need to trade a little
bit more I need one pair of rows to come
off okay now I'm a little bit more happy
a little more happy about things getting
some space
everybody loves space and I just dropped
a piece upon oh oh
am i close to dead Oh No hook up and
then over look up in and over now my
rook gets to play
is he having fun ah there goes the light
square bishop there goes the only bishop
let's get my majority going that's not
the way to get the majority going here
no I want to play let's go up on let's
go up on they have they have a majority
over here I got to stop that majority I
don't have much time uh uh I gotta get
my majority going this is gonna be a
draw isn't it take them come on go go go
go go go go go go time burners where you
at no no I offered rah
they were offering a drop can I get this
huh Oh hope they drop the rook time
burners time burners time burners where
you at
white wins i won oh I didn't have time
to look at the clock they were offering
a dry I wanted to accept it I really did
lose I didn't mean to move my rook there
either
we had about eight seconds it was even
on time hand position if I had a more of
a time advantage I wouldn't have I would
have definitely done time burners but
now when we both had about eight ah man
that's a tough one to stomach not for me
not for me but I know I know I know I
know I know what you're thinking I know
what you're thinking mind reader
mind reader variation okay let's go Jeep
on that year if pawn push everything's
okay let's do this anyhow ah oh okay I
was in check that's a good thing Queen
trade everybody loves a clean trade
right here bishops gonna the pawn is
gonna push oh man hello man I gotta hang
on a tricky night that's my only hope
there's a for coming out
yepper oh man no keep it closed
don't you dare my knight tricky Knight
that's my only hope is a tricky Knight a
tricky tricky Knight come on tricky
Knight come on tricky Knight do
something good do something good tricky
Knight you're not doing anything good
come over here there's tricks over here
is it there oh I'm not getting that
tricky Knight
where's the trick Bob dead checks wait
wait it's a tricky night I got this but
wait there's still more work you're
gonna resign I only have five I don't
have any time I do not have any time
look at my stupid bishop can't win this
you can't win this
did I win Oh David playing again it's
tied what 31 30 oh man oh man oh man oh
man oh man
tricky knights everywhere tricky tricky
tricky Knights there's even a guy named
tricky knight in the chat that's how
tricky they are people create tricky
knight names is he still here
my opponents not moving and I could get
a quick win here from mr. d Prince this
should be a quick one ah okay we have to
play this one Oh take free Knights take
free Knights next time I can't believe I
let that one fly ah just take this go
into a gambit gambit land take my rook
you know you want to take that rook oh
this isn't dangerous for what black this
is dangerous for me
Queens gonna kill me isn't she let's go
here I'm hitting the rook and I'm
defending upon and they're defending
that yeah let's go here what was that
sound
that was a grunt and a half right there
a grunt and a half uh let's come over
here oh man I don't know why over here
but I'm gonna go over here let's do that
oh man I could back up my light square
bishop or defend my queen okay we're
even on time which is wonderful which is
wonderful whoa whoa whoa whoa slow down
we need to trade Queens trade queen time
right here's where you want to be oh
it's a free queen hang on tricky Knights
whoa I was just ready to fall for a
knight f3
oh man that would have been painful
painful very painful hit a rook look for
a meeting too
it looks gonna play to c6 over there I
mean one be scared
he's running let's stop that sort of
let's do a check and then a check here
it's not really working out well just
come over here where does that mean
where is it I don't care
time burners time burners anything
anything anything I want to get made on
h8 made on h8 Oh coming up don't try to
run away King you getting ready to run
away one two three
one and then two three unavoidable
you're gonna move they're not gonna move
they're down on time back to tournament
150 somebody has 170 oh less than eight
minutes here we go here we go I gotta
get this one here I gotta get this let's
roll
come on but he knows about the Queen c7
move they're being sneaky they were
being sneaky watch out for the fork now
they didn't see it fort for Kurowski I'm
gonna take the one that's closer to the
center and try and get this guy I got
him
hang on hang on don't you dare oh man
I'm up on two minor pieces two minor
pieces let's go over here structural
damage structural damage only in chess
will you hear that structural damage
structural damage you gotta watch out
for that structural damage let's do this
it's very scary though I could deal with
that can I got made threats and stuff
defend aged seven
Oh ma'am I'll do this I got to run home
to g7 right here okay safe and sound
okay you know what I'm looking for next
come on Queen trade come on you know you
want to clean trade you know you want to
clean trade it's a good strategy and
you're not material trade those Queens
let's go even if you have to give up
some material probably should just take
it on sea floor first okay tricky
Knights watch out watch out for those
guys anything I need to go quicker
quicker quicker quicker gotta get this
right here Forks tricky night's deadly
Ford of deadly Fork deadly deadly fork
right here anything I take that right
here take this pond run back and over
here push up on don't have any time
anything back to tournament 171 88 oh
he's in striking distance you might get
paired up it could be the big one his
19th this is that right does he have 19
games in diet I of 13 did I read that
right ah that is a lot if I read that
right 19 games do I really only have 13
okay nice I should just pin the knight
pin and then win ah
pin the knight and then win the night oh
this is gonna be brutal isn't it I want
to get right here look for me check
if I move the bishop here the Queen was
gonna go there so my opponents in a
giant knot oh man they are in a giant
knot right here Oh light square
weaknesses oh man
they are in a pickle are they gonna
resign no crashing through on this now
where does that mean I had that cupboard
meetin one two three one two three back
to chairman 2:38 whoa twenty-two three
games more it was 19 now it's 22
well how Wow how do you catch that guy
there's no there's less than four man
these dark squares Queen h4 and do some
weakness it's not really a good thing to
do okay dark squares take that pawn if
it pushes I'm on the rope and the Rope
twice
my queen gonna be trapped I want to play
f5 line up f5 open up that F file keep
the Queen's on the board in this case I
want to attack that King I need to get
quick wins where are these quick wins
throw opinion I need to get more
development in more development more
pieces playing all my pieces need to be
playing lateral movement of the Queen
very easy to miss happens a lot a real
lot are they going to resign I got to
watch out for Maine over here being
sneaky sneak attacks everywhere watch
out for those sneak attacks
okay I can actually get away with this
because I defend with night takes get
away with that one
I'm defending h7 I'm on the rook as well
time situation mate
soon this is me and one two unavoidable
back determined to ten to fifty eight oh
wow man 258 man that is crazytown two
minutes and change I could
I can't even there's no way I'm out 58
points that's crazy that is crazy isn't
it ah how do you come back from that you
don't you don't overcome 58 points in
less than two minutes just doesn't work
that way just does not work that way ah
g4 I wanted to do g4 right there let's
try it again
g4 g5
take that night pac-man mom that rook
king each one can I at least get one
more in one more winner and now jump my
knight right into H five I want to get
break at that no actually right here is
better yeah cuz now the Queen was gonna
be killing me
okay let's do that and I got to defend
this pawn I was getting very very very
serious right there I think these rooks
now looking for me where hmm oh okay I
could give a check give a check I have
the Queen I'm pretty sure I get the
Queen with this line right here right
here right here right here
and then here and then I have made
threat
I got a dodged check another check and
then me coming up right there
back to tournament two 3288 eight more
games played what can you do
ah man 28 seconds 28 seconds remain ah
it's not gonna finish this game is not
gonna finish it's not happening okay I
have that covered actually tell me
let's take here and then this is not
gonna finish not happening the bishops
close to trapped I probably should just
taking it that's it second place
confetti man ahh good games oh I got to
do some homework here what went on 24
games